quand danemark du troll avec lésions à
perpétuité un verdict sans surprise pour
un arc central expulsable à la prison à
vie un vernis assortis d'un commenté
président thomas sorensen
je crois que vous vous en sortez quand
même mieux que le plus peur de vos
victimes qui font plus partie du monde
des vivants
ma fille âme qui est morte oui oui en
mémoire elle a été là tous les jours et
je crois qu'il peut être qu'elle veut un
truc très fier
des nerfs qui lâchent après avoir
attendu ce verdict si longtemps michelle
martin l'ex-femme de marc dutroux et
condamné à 30 ans de prison
aucune circonstance atténuante michel
lelièvre l'homme demain toxicomanes
écopent de 25 ans clémence de la cour en
revanche pour michel nihoul cinq ans de
prison pour trafic de drogue
laetitia de l'est étaient convaincus de
l'implication de news dans son
enlèvement
c'est une déception je ne suis pas quant
à fait contents de ce qu'ils savaient
qu'avec des cours nul mais ma foi - on
accepte quand même c'est que le jury ce
verdict du procès du siècle des anonymes
l'aurait voulu plus sévère je m'excuse
appel de la démo qui tranche avec la
dignité de sabine dardenne l'une des
deux survivantes ou la résignation de
parents pourquoi insatisfait par des
réponses judiciaires
demain il y aura il y aura neuf ans que
les petites ou effet relevé et 1 heure
actuelle baisse c'est toujours la même
chose ça m'a poussé toujours pas qu'une
jambe
pour clore ce procès fleuve le président
a tenu à remercier tous les acteurs et
surtout les jurés la belgique peut être
fier de vous at il dit une belgique qui
veut désormais tourner la page de la
sphère du trou sans renier pour autant
un devoir de mémoire pour les victimes